une autre fille une deuxième fois
distille 48 heures ont maintenant passé
depuis la fantastique arrivée au sprint
de la transatlantique française et
l'enthousiasmé provoqué par le
corps-à-corps birch malinowski s'est
progressivement transformé en altitude
ou presque en angoisse pour alain colas
voilà douze jours maintenant qui n'a
plus donné de ses nouvelles et les
breguet de la marine nationale ont
commencé à ratisser l'atlantique est
le bréguet de la marine nationale basé à
la guadeloupe survolent actuellement
l'atlantique à la recherche des
concurrents qui n'ont pas donné de leurs
nouvelles depuis plusieurs jours parmi
eux alain colas le navigateur français
n'a pas donné signe de vie depuis 14
jours alors démâtage et panne de radio
peut-être cela expliquerait sans retard
et son silence accidents corporels
c'est imaginable car depuis l'accident
de 1976 n'a pas récupéré totalement
l'usagé de son pied son frère
jean-françois évoque cette éventualité
lorsqu'on est seul sur un bateau et peut
se passer des tas de choses et et pour
le moment je ne préfère pas l'envisager
il est handicapé alain colas au son pied
j'imagine le jeune dans une épreuve
comme celle ci avec les difficultés
qu'on connaît
oui il faut beaucoup de courage il a il
a un pied qui est pas le même que notre
âme il a besoin d'y faire de faire très
attention car il n'a aucune sensibilité
son pied tout à fait insensible
s'il se fait le moindre bobo il ne le
sent pas il peut pas et il faut le
surveiller et ça peut tout de suite
prendre des proportions importantes mais
enfin il a l'habitude
il vit maintenant avec ce pied je pense
qu'il pourra je peux bien ce qui peut
parfaitement se débrouiller il l'a
prouvé
puis des nouvelles des autres
concurrents jeunes riguidel déjà victime
d'un abordage avec un ferry boat au
départ a eu la malchance de heurter un
rocher à antigua son bateau est très
alliés mais le skippeur est sain et sauf
ont voté cet après midi